pas de panique à bord le fun et la
vitesse d'abord pas de panique à bord
c'est les rats c'est les Ratz qui sont
la pour ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et oui je suis redit Juliette je suis
très heureux très content de vous
accueillir dans mon studio
d'enregistrement alors venez je vais
vous montrer un peu comment ça se passe
comment je travaille dans ce petit
endroit très sympathique suivez-moi
[Musique]
alors ici qu'est-ce qui se passe ça fait
à peu près 25 ans que je travaille dans
cet endroit et je compose et créer écrit
pour plein de projets différents alors
on peut voir ici effectivement que j'ai
fait des choses comme les Minikeums par
exemple
j'ai également fait les Ratz pas de
panique à bord
[Musique]
le fun et la vitesse d'abord
qui sont là pour ça donc j'ai composé
plein de petites chansons pour des
programmes pour la télé j'ai aussi fait
des choses plus larges et ouvertes parce
que ici je travaille sur tout type de
projet donc que ça peut aller des
projets pour enfants des comédies
musicales et en général on me demande de
prendre en main toute la chaîne de
création d'un projet ça va de l'écriture
à la réalisation à l'enregistrement au
mixage tout se passe ici voilà
coupez voilà il y a plus rien que la
voix
voilà la batterie par exemple après qui
va arriver là c'est la guitare
voilà donc ici on peut faire absolument
tout c'est un vrai studio professionnel
madame s'il vous plaît James
[Musique]
donc moi j'ai commencé très très petit
quand j'avais à peu près
14 ans à peu près 12 14 ans je voulais
chanter chanter et j'ai chanté dans dans
des chorales et tout ça et j'ai eu la
vocation en étant roi mage dans une
crèche et puis j'entendais ces accords
magnifiques je me suis dit mais c'est ce
que je vais faire je vais être musicien
j'ai appris à jouer de la guitare pour
commencer et je suis rentré dans un
groupe de rock à Lyon pendant des années
qui s'appelle afterlife
plein de comédie musicale mes flowers
ensuite Moïse où j'étais pharaon ensuite
Starmania Starmania où j'étais gourou et
ensuite j'ai fait du travail en studio
j'ai fait plein de choses de la pub
beaucoup beaucoup de pubs nouveau geste
pourrait graphique fixe un mauve garanti
par les laboratoires Garnier et plus
récemment j'ai eu la chance de faire
partie de Notre-Dame de Paris
the famous one
[Musique]
il y a eu des moments difficiles parce
que comme je suis un
musicien éclectique parfois j'ai fait
des peut-être pas les bons choix au bon
moment
mais dans l'ensemble j'ai toujours
réussi à rebondir et à passer d'un truc
à un autre quoi parce que quand je suis
pas sur scène je suis en studio quand je
suis pas en studio
j'écris donc je n'ai pas de de honte
parfois avoir accepté de faire des
choses un peu moins
moins dans la lumière entre guillemets
c'est-à-dire oui on aimerait tous faire
un film avec Spielberg voilà mais bon on
en fait avec un réalisateur moins connu
donc je ne vois pas de mal à s'instruire
à apprendre de choses qui ne sont pas
forcément celles qu'on pensait être les
bonnes mais qui peuvent nous aider à
devenir meilleur je dirais faut y aller
faut croire en soi et puis être
travailleur faut bosser il faut avoir
envie envie